gestion de la pandémie conflit
réchauffement climatique dans un monde
en pleine mutation
l'onu doit donc faire face à de nouveaux
défis pour les générations futures
on va en parler tout de suite avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales avec nous également
anaïs or si avec climatologue au
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement
spécialiste de l'antarctique
jean-christophe gallien géopolitologue
nous a également rejoint bonsoir et
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
de nombreux défis donc affronter pour
les nuls et une alerte cet après-midi
d'antonio goûter res le chef de
l'organisation il a appelé en premier
lieu à éviter une nouvelle guerre froide
claude blanche maison antonio good t rès
il pensait notamment à la rivalité
sino-américaine c'est cela oui bien sûr
je crois que monsieur couture yes a
raison le risque est réel et on l'a bien
vu aujourd'hui en écoutant et le
discours du côté américain on a eu
l'impression de voir l'aigle américain
montrer ses griffes et du côté chinois
le dragon chinois rentrer lé ciel alors
monsieur trump en effet a accusé de
façon tout à fait frontale la chine
d'avoir infecté le monde entier avec le
vide 19 d'avoir empêché l'om est
organisation mondiale de la santé de
réagir à temps et par la même occasion
il a accusé la chine d' infiltrer et
ainsi d'influencer toutes les
organisations internationales
il ya aussi accusé d'être un prédateur
technologique et de fossés de manière
insidieuse les relations économiques
internationales
et puis finalement il a dit en concluant
que les états unis avaient dépensé 2500
milliards de dollars en quatre ans pour
leur défense c'est-à-dire pour renforcer
leur armée ce qui est naturellement
colossal et il
ai dit la vérité c'est-à-dire nous
sommes le pays le plus puissant du monde
et lorsque nous négocions les accords
bilatéraux et bien c'est une
contribution à la paix du monde alors
al'inverse jean ping s'est montré le
chantre du multilatéralisme
l'apôtre du libéralisme est évidemment a
soutenu toutes les organisations
internationales il a aussi effectivement
souhaité que tous les pays coopèrent
pour redresser l'économie mondiale
frappée de plein fouet par la pandémie
alors jean christophe gallier un bon
coup beaucoup ont souligné aujourd'hui
les relations difficiles entre les états
membres de l'onu il ya également ce
contexte de crise de coronavirus le chef
de l'onu a donné 100 jours à la
communauté internationale pour un cessez
le feu
on imagine les obstacles gigantesque
alors comment vous analysé cette raison
d'espérer d'antonio goûter res est ce
que c'est un voeu pieux est ce que c'est
possible avec les forces de bonne
volonté comme viens de dire emmanuel
macron quel est votre regard
malheureusement c'est un voeu pieux
cette analyse des presque de désespoir
finalement de la situation aujourd'hui
crois que cette maison qui à 75 ans elle
n'est plus adapté au monde multipolaire
est assez volonté de puissance
relativement exacerbée qui se combine
avec il faut il faut le dire et c'est
assez dense à défonce à des temps
exponentielle aussi tout à tout s'est
accéléré c'est pas le coc vie qui
finalement qui est un facteur
accélération supplémentaire qui a changé
la donne c'est finalement les grandes
tendances à l'oeuvre qui sont évidemment
cette fracturation cette fracture du
monde entre différents blocs mais elle
est naturelle de vie que sur une
augmentation exponentielle la population
des échanges des flux de communication
tout ça participe d'un temps qui est
très incertain dont très peu sont
capables de deux de voir au delà
finalement du trimestre voire du
semestre qui vient
et donc c'est compliqué pour une vieille
maison comme celle là que de jouer
finalement plutôt les pompiers après des
incendies qui se répètent et qui
finalement sont sains malgré tout trouve
parfois notamment au conseil de sécurité
dès capacités de solutions dont que le
secrétaire général appelle à son jouera
à une paix globale on peut imaginer
effectivement que c'est un beau message
mais on y croit très peu parce que
encore une fois ça n'est pas la réalité
de ce que vivent les différentes du
monde et ça n'est pas simplement encore
une fois parce qu'il ya des acteurs de
différents blocs qui veulent interagir
ils sont de 31 ans
les temps ont changé les temps ont
changé et tous les paramètres
aujourd'hui sont des paramètres de
friction des paramètres de tension il
n'y a que très peu d'espacé très peu de
géographie lit très peu de thématiques
qui ne donne pas lieu finalement à des
volontés encore une fois d'en découdre
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
finalement au total malgré ces tensions
extrêmes malgré cette incertitude on a
évidemment quelque chose qui se passe
pas si mal et donc le nu dans ce
contexte au lac est une maison du commun
qui est une maison ont normalement
viendrait
le multilatéralisme tenter de corriger
le monde multipolaire de cette ambition
multipolaire et elle a du mal à agir
mais finalement de temps en temps malgré
tout elle pose son empreinte notamment
quand il s'agit de trouver des solutions
et des insomnies l'eau et metz a été
critiqué mais l'om est travail certaines
actions encore une fois des forces et
les casques bleus sont toujours là il y
a des points positifs mais évidemment
c'est compliqué de faire face à ces
évolutions
anaïs or si jean-claude gagnants
viennent nous dire tout s'est accéléré
le réchauffement climatique également
c'est aussi un cap pour l'onu son chef a
parlé d'un nouveau contrat social avec
qui doit assurer la transition vers les
énergies renouvelables pour atteindre
l'objectif de zéro émission net d'ici
c'est un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui pour
pour l'organisation
ah c'est sûr c'est le changement
climatique c'est un accélérateur de
toutes nos difficultés quelque part et
ça touche aux choses et plus basiques de
l'existence ionel comme l'accès à l'eau
comme l'agriculture les chemins on peut
pas se passer comment comprendre
justement que cette question climatique
aujourd'hui elle ne fait pas consensus
on se souvient les états unis s'étaient
retirés des accords de paris sur le
climat n'est sorti eh bien je sport
qu'elle ne fait pas consensus parce que
la solution est difficile c'est un petit
peu comme mon grand-père qui aa du
diabète et qui mange un gâteau à la
crème platinum c'est pas qui c'est pas
bon pour lui le 4 la crème jusqu'à quand
il est devant lui il n'a pas résisté
c'est juste aussi simple que ça en fait
c'est juste difficile de prendre des
décisions difficiles
j'ai tellement c'est de ne rien faire
que pousse la balle
la personne d'après je pense qu'il faut
pas nécessairement chercher plus loin
dans la difficulté qu'on à prendre en
main et les enjeux de demain mais quand
même il faut que les choses bougent
claude blanche raison c'est un véritable
enjeu diplomatique cette lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique au fond ou
alors ça passait bien
un peu au second plan pour les
différents états non je crois que ta
véritable enjeu en effet nous sommes un
petit peu au bord du précipice je crois
que là-dessus tous les scientifiques
sont d'accord
maintenant ce qui se passe c'est que les
politiques et d'ailleurs les diplomates
ont très souvent un langage qui est un
langage politiquement correct sur le
sujet c'est à dire qu'ils adoptent ou
qu'ils acceptent les conclusions du
sommet de paris et aider des sommets qui
ont suivi la grande différence c'est que
depuis que monsieur trump et prévient
les états unis monsieur trump est l'un
des premiers à sortir du politiquement
correct et du coup a dénoncé l'accord
annoncé d'accord est effectivement pour
son électorat
c'est une bonne chose parce que il peut
dire à jean qui aura sur l'électorat
je ne me laisse pas conter par des
accords internationaux qui imposerait
des contraintes injustifiée à l'économie
américaine et du coup d'autres pays
molson à rossi est également essayé à un
moment donné effectivement envisage de
ne pas respecter et beaucoup de pays au
bout du compte quel que soit les propos
qu'ils tiennent sur le plan politique ne
respectent pas les contraintes qui
résulte de ses engagements pour limiter
le réchauffement climatique
donc on est là un petit peu dans un jeu
qui relève un petit peu d'hypocrisie
la plupart des pays se conforme au
langage des plus politiquement correct
mais quitte à ne pas complètement
appliquée les les conclusions les
directives desmet de paris les suivantes
alors jean claude galien je vouvoyais
hocher de la tête vous souhaitez réagir
aux propos de claude manche maison
je crois que malheureusement
c'est ainsi que c'est un sujet qui
encore une fois un sujet extrêmement
globalisé hyperlocal et c'est l'exact
moment que nous vivons un moment où nous
voyons le virus nous dit bien qu'il n'ya
pas de local qu'ils soient à l'abri du
global ni du le global ni même lui est à
l'abri des effets du local or c'est pas
à l'environnement malheureusement je ne
crois pas que ça soit aujourd'hui on
puisse peut dire l'enjeu géopolitique et
diplomatique majeur je pense
qu'aujourd'hui et la crise de du virus
la gym a accéléré cette tendance que
nous voyons depuis la coop de paris
s'est plaint d'indicateurs et dans les
mondes indicateurs montrent qu'au
contraire les marchés que l'ensemble des
facteurs d'investissement notamment sur
le terrain energy ont largement baissé
le renouvelable pour aller vers le faut
aussi voir le nucléaire il ya il ya donc
des évolutions qui ne sont pas très au
delà des prises et des incantations
politique on voit à répétition je crois
que malheureusement les peuples ont bien
compris et c'est très difficile ensuite
sur le plan individuel sur le plan comme
toit du local dauphin référence à cette
histoire de diabète dont vous parlez
très justement thaler et de manger wi fi
nalement a tous très envie de manger le
gâteau parce que finalement on voit bien
que au niveau global va les grandes
actions les grands leaders ne sont pas
au rendez vous chacun pour soi il ya
presque même une alliance pour le coup à
fond jusque là une alliance entre là
pour le coup les états unis la chine
l'inde et l'australie y sont d'autres
états pour dire mais après tout ça n'est
pas l'enjeu principal nous avons
d'autres chats à fouetter d'autres
bataille prioritaire et nous souhaitons
individuellement pouvoir avoir
l'attitude nous leurs avoirs et donc au
delà des incantations diplomatique et
géopolitique
on est très loin finalement termes
d'actions hors mis le local
hormis les choses qui se passent dans
les villes dans les régions pour des
stratégies parfois beaucoup plus
ambitieuse on n'est pas au rendez vous
et je crains que malheureusement les
quelques mois qui viennent ne soit pas
non plus au rendez vous malgré la coop à
glasgow
vous verrez des incantations mais vous
ne verrez pas des grands actes concrets
parce que le concret manque
effectivement
il sort si je rappelle vous êtes
climatologues vous rejoignez ses propos
de jean-christophe gallien sur cette
question du réchauffement climatique qui
dit oui peut-être et bien dans les mois
à venir il y aura des paroles mais pour
les actes qu'il faudra attendre en
attendant il ya des questions
économiques par exemple qui sont plus
importantes
ça c'est pas venir chez les questions
économiques sont importants mais s'il ya
un domaine dans lequel le mult analyse
multi l'état marche super bien c'est
justement la science parce que ce soit
pour le virus la recherche d'une
solution que ce soit dans la recherche
sur le climat
en fait on est une grande famille
scientifique mondiale et c'est la
coopération qui prime et celle échanges
de savoirs qui prime
et là il ya vraiment pas de frontières
sûres comment est-ce qu'on va réussir à
bien comprendre quels sont les enjeux de
demain et savoir quels sont les dangers
auxquels on fait passer comment est-ce
qu'on va y répondre ça c'est quand même
un point positif
tu montes et l'interallié claude blanche
maison je vous laisse la parole pour
conclure sur la forme de cette rencontre
des prises de parole à distance en
raison du coronavirus finalement est
cette formule à ce que ce n'est pas
l'occasion de cristalliser encore plus
les relations entre les uns et les
autres sur ces différents sujets
convient d'évoquer notamment la question
climatique
si vous êtes avoir interrogé le
diplomate que je suis naturellement ce
genre de réunion c'est l'horreur
puisqu'on a sans qu'on aura à la fin de
la semaine 193 déclarations plus ou
moins longues juxtaposées sans aucun
sans aucun dialogue
alors ces déclarations sont utiles sont
importantes puisque c'est la position de
chacun des pays à un moment donné avec
l'accent mis sur les points qui
ressemble le plus le plus important mais
les autres années
sans coronavirus cette semaine dit à
haut niveau à new york aux nations unies
c'était la semaine de tous les contacts
c'était là que se faisait la vraie
diplomatie c'est à dire qu' il y avait
des négociations
les gens avaient des rencontres
bilatérales aux besoins des rencontres
improvisées et faisait avancer des
projets qui n'étaient pas des heures des
projets nécessairement à l'ordre du jour
donc ceci est bien l onu en sera privée
cette année puisque le corps à un virus
fait que que ça n'est pas que ce n'est
pas possible je crois que c'est très
c'est assez grave pour pour pour l'onu
monsieur poutine a proposé qu'il y ait
lorsque la situation sanitaire le
permettra un sommet des cinq dirigeants
des cinq membres permanents du conseil
de sécurité
c'est une proposition d'ailleurs qui
rejoint une proposition française qui
avait déjà était fait dans le passé
j'imagine que ça dépendra très largement
du résultat des élections américaines du
3 novembre prochain je ne suis pas
certain que monsieur trump soit très
friands de ce genre de réunions avec
monsieur jean ping et avec les autres
merci beaucoup à tous les trois de nous
avoir aidés de décrypter cette assemblée
générale à l'onu notamment sur cette
question du réchauffement climatique
merci à vous claude blanchemaison je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales merci anaïs or
s'ils avaient climatologue au
laboratoire des sciences et du climat et
de l'environnement et spécialiste de
l'antarctique et merci à vous jean
christophe gallien géopolitologue